My wife and I are standing at the door to our place, and we're arguing. A delivery guy has arrived with something, and it's early morning, and I hold the dog and I ask her to go to the door. And she doesn't want to go to the door because of the way that she's dressed. And I insist, no, no, no, no. It's fine. And we go around on this for a while, and the guy's at the door and I don't give in and she finally goes to the door.
我和我妻子站在家门口，我们正在争吵。快递员送了东西过来，当时才清晨，我抱着狗，请她去开门。但她因为穿着的原因不想去开门。我坚持说不，没关系。我们就这个问题争执了一会儿，那人还在门口，我不肯让步，她最终还是去开了门。
And then the guy leaves, and she's mad, and she cannot understand why I made her do that. And finally, I look at her, and I see what it is that she's talking about. She's in an undershirt and pajama bottoms. And I see why she wouldn't want to go to the door. I see it. I see it. But what I say is, "That shirt's not so revealing." This just comes out of me, without thinking. A complete lie.
然后那个人离开了，她很生气，无法理解我为什么要逼她那么做。最后，我看着她，我明白了她在说什么。她穿着汗衫和睡裤。我明白了为什么她不想去开门。我懂了。我懂了。但我却说：“那件衬衫又没那么暴露。”这完全是脱口而出，没经过大脑。一个彻头彻尾的谎言。
And she says, you know, this is that thing you do. This is that the thing right here. You can't admit when you did something wrong, which she is totally right about. She's so right, in fact, that I still don't admit it. Though, to describe it this way makes it seem like I'm actually doing a computation in my head and thinking things through and weighing things out. Should I admit it? Should I not admit it? And then I conclude, no. No, don't do it, don't admit it, don't give in.
她说，你知道，你总是这样。就是这样。你做错了事却从不肯承认，她说得完全正确。事实上，她太对了，以至于我仍然不肯承认。虽然这样描述起来，好像我是在脑子里计算、权衡各种利弊。我应该承认吗？我不应该承认吗？然后我得出结论：不，不要承认，不要认输。
But, in fact, all this happens in an instant in my head. It's like lightning. There's no thought at all. I say, no, no, no, the shirt's fine, I don't see a problem. And then she points out that it's crazy-making, living with me. That if I could just admit that I did something wrong at the beginning, her life would be so much better. This happens all the time.
但实际上，这一切在我脑海中瞬间就发生了。就像闪电一样。根本没有任何思考。我说，不，不，不，衬衫没问题，我不觉得有什么问题。然后她指出，跟我生活在一起简直让人抓狂。如果我一开始就能承认自己做错了，她的生活会好过得多。这种情况经常发生。
Part of getting older, I think, is learning that you do these things, without thinking, that you are not proud of. I have a list. I interrupt people, I snap at people, I get a condescending, know-it-all tone sometimes without even knowing I'm doing it. I fake laugh at stuff I don't find funny, because I'm only half listening. And while I'm self-absorbed enough to do all that, unfortunately I am not so self-absorbed that I don't notice the look on other people's faces and realize what I've done.
我想，变老的一部分过程，就是学会意识到自己会做出这些不经思考、让自己引以为耻的事情。我有一张清单。我打断别人说话，对人发火，有时会在不知不觉中流露出居高临下的自以为是的语气。我假装对一些我觉得不好笑的事情发笑，因为我根本没在认真听。虽然我自恋到会做所有这些事，但很不幸，我还没迟钝到察觉不出别人的脸色，意识不到自己做了什么。
This is a very bad middle ground to be in. You know, if I were more sensitive, I wouldn't be doing these things in the first place. And if I was less sensitive, I wouldn't notice what an ass I am, which would be less painful, for me.
这是一个非常糟糕的中间地带。你知道，如果我更敏感一点，一开始就不会做这些事。如果我迟钝一点，我就不会意识到自己是个混蛋，这对我也许会少一点痛苦。
Most of us have these things, these little devils inside of us that we're fighting against. And some of the devils aren't so little. You know? Sometimes you're spending your life fighting one of these devils and then you become president of the United States, and somehow end up messing around with an intern, which ruins your presidency and possibly, depending on how you see it, leads to the election of a guy who sends our nation into what becomes a very unpopular war.
我们大多数人都有这些东西，内心深处对抗着的小恶魔。有些恶魔可不那么小。你知道吗？有时你一生都在与这些恶魔中的一个战斗，然后你成了美国总统，却莫名其妙地跟实习生搞在了一起，这毁了你的总统任期，并且根据你的看法，可能还导致了一个把国家拖入一场极不受欢迎的战争的人当选。
Well, that's the subject of today's radio program. From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life , distributed by Public Radio International. I'm Ira Glass. Today we have stories of people for whom fighting the devils inside them, it became the biggest struggle of their lives.
好吧，这就是今天广播节目的主题。来自芝加哥 WBEZ 电台，这是《美国生活》，由国际公共广播电台发行。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天，我们带来了一些故事，讲述那些与内心恶魔搏斗的人，这成了他们一生中最重大的斗争。
In Act One, a guy goes to extraordinary lengths to rid himself of certain feelings, feelings of prejudice, feelings of bigotry, that he's having and finds he cannot control. In Act Two, we let the devils inside people's heads speak, en masse, here on the radio. In Act Three, a man starts off by battling certain doubts in his head, and ends up in a real biblical stand-off with a demon who shows up one day in his college classroom. Stay with us.
在第一幕中，一个人竭尽全力摆脱某些感受——那些他无法控制的偏见和偏执感受。在第二幕中，我们让人们脑海中的恶魔在这里通过广播发声。在第三幕中，一个男人从头脑中与某些疑虑作斗争，最终在大学教室里与一天突然出现的恶魔进行了一场真正的圣经式的对峙。请继续收听。
Act one, And So We Meet Again. So let's say you find yourself bothered by some very extreme and unreasonable things knocking around in your head. Maybe you try to fix that by doing something extreme. Lisa Pollak has the story of one guy who did just that. We first broadcast her story a year ago.
第一幕，我们又见面了。假设你发现自己被脑海中挥之不去的一些极端且不合理的想法所困扰。也许你会试图通过做一些极端的事情来解决它。丽莎·波拉克讲述了一个男人正是这样做的故事。我们在一年前首次播出了她的故事。
Last winter, if you happened to be watching the campus TV station at Parkland College in Champaign, Illinois, you might have seen this.
去年冬天，如果你恰好在观看伊利诺伊州香槟市帕克兰学院的校园电视台，你可能看过这个。
Happy Holidays from the Parkland College Business Club.
帕克兰学院商业俱乐部祝大家节日快乐。
Come join us.
欢迎加入我们。
A video montage of Season's Greetings from campus clubs  and departments.
一个来自校园俱乐部和院系的节日问候视频剪辑。
Happy Holidays from Financial Aid.
助学金办公室祝大家节日快乐。
Happy Holidays from the Occupational Therapy Assistant Program.
职业治疗助理项目祝大家节日快乐。
And if you couldn't pull yourself away, you'd eventually get to this. Two guys, one slight and bearded, with dark skin speaking Arabic.
如果你无法移开视线，你最终会看到这个。两个男人，一个瘦削留着胡子，肤色较深，说着阿拉伯语。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[说着阿拉伯语]
And the other, a tall, broad shouldered white guy with the translation.
另一个是个身材高大、肩膀宽阔的白人，负责翻译。
Greetings from the Muslim Student Association at Parkland College. We want to wish you and everyone else a happy Holiday season.
帕克兰学院穆斯林学生协会向大家致以问候。我们祝愿您和所有人节日快乐。
The second guy, the one speaking English, that's Sam Slaven. And what he doesn't say in the video is that even though he's in the Muslim Student Association, he's not a Muslim. He doesn't want to be a Muslim. In fact, not so long ago, he couldn't stand to be in the same room with Muslims.
第二个人，那个说英语的，是萨姆·斯莱文。他在视频中没说的是，尽管他在穆斯林学生协会，但他并不是穆斯林。他不想成为穆斯林。事实上，不久前，他甚至无法和穆斯林待在同一个房间里。
The idea of Sam joining the Muslim Student Association was so improbable that even some of the people who knew him best thought he was kidding when he first told them about it. It's not a choice anybody would expect from a guy who use words like this to describe Muslims--
萨姆加入穆斯林学生协会的想法是如此不可思议，以至于一些最了解他的人在最初听到时以为他在开玩笑。对于一个用这些词来形容穆斯林的人来说，这绝不是任何人会期待的选择——
You know, we call them Haji or raghead or camel jockey. All kinds of things. I don't know. I don't think most of them make your cut here. Mother [BLEEP], you know. [BLEEP].
你知道，我们称他们为哈吉（Haji）、裹头巾的（raghead）或骆驼骑师（camel jockey）。各种各样的称呼。我不知道。我觉得他们大多数人甚至没资格入我的眼。操（Mother [BLEEP]），你知道的。[BLEEP]。
To understand home Sam went from being that guy to the guy extending Seasons Greetings on behalf of the Muslim Student Association, and then even becoming friends, real friends, with the bearded guy in that video, you have to go back a few years to the first place Sam ever really learned about Muslims. It wasn't Parkland College. It was Iraq.
要了解萨姆如何从那样一个人变成代表穆斯林学生协会致以节日问候的人，甚至变成那个视频中胡子男人的朋友，真正的朋友，你必须回到几年前萨姆第一次真正了解穆斯林的那个地方。那不是帕克兰学院。那是伊拉克。
Sam's from Indiana. After high school, he enrolled at Purdue. But college wasn't for him back then, so he dropped out and joined the Army. When he was sent to Baghdad in 2003, at the start of the war, he was Sergeant Sam Slaven, of the 2nd Armored Calvary. He didn't know much about the people in Iraq, or their religion, but he knew he wanted to help them. And, at first, it seemed like they wanted that, too.
萨姆来自印第安纳州。高中毕业后，他进入了普渡大学。但那时候大学不适合他，所以他退学并加入了军队。当他 2003 年战争刚开始时被派往巴格达，他是第 2 装甲骑兵团的萨姆·斯莱文下士。他不太了解伊拉克人或他们的宗教，但他知道他想帮助他们。起初，看起来他们也确实需要帮助。
In fact, listening to Sam describe the early days of the invasion, I realized I'd forgotten that scenes like this ever existed.
事实上，听着萨姆描述入侵初期的日子，我意识到我已经忘记了这样的场景曾经存在过。
Nobody shooting at us. They were just, you know, happy to see us, glad to be there. They'd bring tea out for us and sit and socialize. We even had one family bake us a cake.
没人向我们开枪。他们只是，你知道，很高兴看到我们，很高兴我们在那里。他们会为我们端茶送水，坐下来社交。甚至有一个家庭为我们烤了蛋糕。
After a few months of that treatment, it's no wonder that when Sam came under fire for the first time, outside a power station he was guarding, he was truly surprised.
享受了几个月这样的待遇后，难怪当萨姆在看守发电站外第一次遭到袭击时，他感到非常震惊。
It just didn't make sense to have somebody right there shooting at us. And I was just like, this is ridiculous. What are you doing? Because, you know, I'm going to have to shoot back. And, you know, we did.
有人在那里向我们开枪根本说不通。我当时就想，这太荒谬了。你们在干什么？因为，你知道，我不得不还击。然后，你知道，我们确实还击了。
As the insurgency got going, so did Sam's piecemeal education in Islam. His unit was stationed in Sadr City, where the cleric Muqtada al-Sadr was building his own militia. And translators told the soldiers, Iraqis were being urged to, quote, "Kill the infidels."
随着叛乱开始，萨姆对伊斯兰教的零星了解也随之开始了。他的部队驻扎在萨德尔城，穆克塔达·萨德尔神职人员正在建立自己的民兵组织。翻译告诉士兵们，伊拉克人被敦促，引用，“杀死异教徒”。
And I guess we were the infidels, or whatever, so it seemed like the Imams telling the people that just kind of influenced everybody to go ahead and conduct those actions against us. And we were pretty upset, just at Islam because their leaders were the ones telling them to do that. At least that's what we were told.
我想我们就是异教徒，或者别的什么，所以似乎是伊玛目告诉人们这样做，才导致每个人都开始针对我们采取行动。我们对伊斯兰教感到非常愤怒，因为是他们的领导人在告诉他们那样做。至少我们是这么被告知的。
Then came the day that changed things for a lot of guys in Sam's unit. On October 9, 2003, his platoon was out on patrol. On a nearby street, another platoon from the unit drove straight into an ambush. They were lured in by a woman and child pretending they needed help.
接着是改变了萨姆部队中许多人命运的那一天。2003 年 10 月 9 日，他的排正在巡逻。在附近的一条街上，该部队的另一个排直接陷入了伏击。他们被一个假装需要帮助的女人和孩子引诱进去。
They stopped to help them and a couple of the privates saw people running with guns, and then just everything let loose. IEDs, RPGs, and rifles and machine guns and just so many, so many guns going off all at once. And I'd never even seen anything like it in a war movie. It was literally a wall of red just moving from left to right and right to left. With all these bullets and the crossfiring. And, of course, we weren't armored. We didn't even have doors on our vehicles. There was nothing we could do. We could have stand there and traded fire with them all day long, but, you know, just the numbers. There's no way we would have survived.
他们停下来帮忙，几个二等兵看到有人带着枪跑过来，然后一切都失控了。简易爆炸装置、火箭推进榴弹、步枪、机枪，所有枪支同时开火。我甚至在战争电影里都没见过那样的场面。那简直是一道红色的墙，从左到右，从右到左。到处是子弹和交火。当然，我们没有装甲。我们的车上甚至连车门都没有。我们无能为力。我们可以站在那里整天和他们对射，但是，你知道，人数差距太大了。我们根本不可能幸存。
It was just terrifying. We weren't in the worst part of the whole thing, but it was still the scariest thing I've ever seen, probably ever will see.
那太可怕了。我们不在整个事件中最危险的地方，但这仍然是我见过的最可怕的事情，可能以后也不会再见了。
Two guys from Sam's unit were killed that night. And the Americans felt betrayed. The ambush was so big that plenty of the locals must have known about it, but no one, not any of the people they'd been trying to help, had warned them. After that, Sam says, he could never really look at Iraqis the same way.
那天晚上萨姆部队里有两名士兵阵亡。美国人感到被背叛了。伏击规模如此之大，当地人一定有不少人知道，但没有一个人——那些他们试图帮助的人——警告过他们。在那之后，萨姆说，他再也无法用同样的眼光看待伊拉克人了。
I mean, just from that point, we were just like, you know, we ought to just kill all these people, just to be safe. Instead of saying hello to them, you tell them, F you, or some sort of insult. We knew plenty of them in their own language there, and had no problems talking about them, or their mothers or whatever.
我是说，从那时起，我们就想，你知道，我们应该杀了这些所有人，以保平安。与其跟他们打招呼，不如直接对他们说，去你妈的，或者其他侮辱性的话。我们那里的人懂不少他们的语言，谈论他们或他们的母亲什么的，根本没有任何心理负担。
It was a two-way street there. They hated us more and we hated them more. The feeling really was shared throughout our unit. One day I walked in and we had a TV and DVD player set up. There was this group of privates, they're all great kids, and they were yelling and cheering and I was, like, what is this? They kept rewinding part of this movie, and they'd just keep playing it. It was from the movie Rules of Engagement , where Samuel L. Jackson tells some marines, waste 'em, and all the guys open up on this crowd of Arabs and just kills everybody in it.
那是双向的。他们更恨我们，我们也更恨他们。这种感觉确实在我们部队中普遍存在。有一天我走进去，我们装了一台电视机和 DVD 播放器。有一群二等兵，他们都是很棒的孩子，他们在尖叫和欢呼，我就问，这是什么？他们一直在倒带电影的一部分，一遍又一遍地播放。那是电影《交战规则》里的片段，塞缪尔·杰克逊告诉一些海军陆战队员，“干掉他们”，然后所有人对着一群阿拉伯人开火，杀了所有人。
And they'd yell and cheer and rewind it and watch it again and just rewind it. Because it's what they wanted to do.
他们一边尖叫欢呼，一边倒带再看，一遍又一遍。因为那正是他们想做的事情。
And was it what you wanted to do, too?
这也是你想做的事情吗？
Oh yeah.
哦，是的。
It's not what he did do, Sam told me, and I want to be clear about that. I spoke to an officer who was one of Sam's superiors back then, and he vouched for Sam's conduct, his adherence to the rules of engagement, the real ones, not the Hollywood ones.
萨姆告诉我，这不是他真正做的事情，我想明确这一点。我采访了一位当时是萨姆上级的军官，他为萨姆的行为做了担保，证明他遵守了交战规则，是真正的规则，不是好莱坞电影里的那些。
Sam's feelings didn't go away when he got back to the States. If anything, they festered. When his year in Iraq was up, he was assigned to an Army recruiting battalion, and stationed in Miami. Which sounds like a nice change of pace for a guy fresh from a war zone, but it wasn't.
萨姆回到美国后，这些情绪并没有消失。如果说有什么改变的话，那就是更加恶化了。他在伊拉克待了一年后，被分配到陆军征兵营，驻扎在迈阿密。这听起来对一个刚从战区回来的人来说是个不错的节奏调整，但事实并非如此。
Because I was in south Florida, it looked a lot like around Baghdad, where we were. It had the palm trees and the canals and it was hot. And between my apartment and recruiting station, there was a mosque. I'd see that and I could physically feel myself tense up. My heart would start pounding, and just make me angry. It's like, oh, I've got to watch out for this place because they're going to run out of that place with guns and just shoot me up.
因为我所在的南佛罗里达州，看起来很像我们待过的巴格达周围。那里有棕榈树、运河，而且很热。在我的公寓和征兵站之间，有一座清真寺。我一看到那个，就能感觉到自己的身体紧绷起来。心跳加速，让我感到愤怒。就像是，哦，我得小心这个地方，因为他们可能会从里面拿着枪跑出来把我突突了。
And when you would see people go into the mosque?
当你看到人们进入清真寺时会怎样？
Well, yeah, I was just like, maybe we should copy down some license plate numbers. Which, it's the same thing we were doing in Iraq. Just keep an eye out on these people, see where they're going. I had just become more angry. And I'd talk to other soldiers in my station, but none of them had ever been to Iraq.
好吧，是的，我当时就想，也许我们应该记下一些车牌号。这和我们在伊拉克做的事情一样。盯着这些人，看看他们要去哪里。我变得越来越愤怒。我和站里的其他士兵谈过，但他们中没有人去过伊拉克。
I'd be like, you know, don't you think we ought to watch out for these people? Thinking, hey, man, these people are out to get us. But nobody else is seeing this but me.
我会说，你知道，你不觉得我们应该提防这些人吗？心想，嘿，伙计，这些人想对我们不利。但除了我以外，没有人看到这一点。
Sam began to have nightmares and trouble sleeping, and other symptoms of PTSD, Post Traumatic Stress Disorder. We've all heard of PTSD, but we don't usually hear the details of what it actually feels like to have it. Falling apart isn't something soldiers brag about. But once, at the end of an interview, I asked Sam if he ever hit bottom, and he said yes.
萨姆开始做噩梦，睡眠困难，并出现了其他创伤后应激障碍 (PTSD) 的症状。我们都听说过 PTSD，但我们通常听不到患有这种病到底是什么感觉。崩溃不是士兵们会吹嘘的事情。但有一次，在采访结束时，我问萨姆他是否曾经跌入谷底，他说是的。
I was sitting in my recruiting office, and I was sitting in the far back, and a new recruiter, even newer than I was, they had him up front practicing his little speeches he's supposed to give there on all of us recruiters. He hadn't been to Iraq, but he was giving a speech on how not bad Iraq was. I was just sitting in the back of the room and I was like, I just can't take this, knowing that we're lying to these kids, we're training people to lie to these kids. And I just left the office, went into the small storage area there and just sat down and I just broke down. I was crying, I couldn't take it. And a female recruiter came in, asked me, what's wrong? And I was like, I just can't take this any more. I just had to go home and just quit. And that's totally unacceptable in the Army, and even more unacceptable in recruiting.
我坐在征兵办公室里，坐在最里面，有一个新来的征兵员，比我还新，他们让他坐在前台练习他要在我们这些征兵员面前做的小演讲。他没去过伊拉克，但他正在发表关于伊拉克并不糟糕的演讲。我只是坐在房间后面，我想，我受不了了，知道我们在向这些孩子撒谎，我们在训练人们向这些孩子撒谎。我直接离开了办公室，去了后面的小储藏室，坐下来，我就崩溃了。我哭了，我受不了了。一个女征兵员走了进来，问我怎么了？我说，我再也受不了了。我只想回家辞职。这在军队里是完全不可接受的，在征兵工作中更是如此。
Really, if anything, I was doing recruiting a favor just because how many people are going to come in and join the Army when they see another recruiter, the only war vet in there, crying because he can't stand the war anymore?
真的，如果说有什么的话，我这样做其实是帮了征兵工作的忙，因为当看到另一个征兵员，这里唯一的战争老兵，因为无法忍受战争而哭泣时，还有多少人会加入军队？
After that day, Sam got help. He started treatment for PTSD, retired from the Army, moved to Champaign, where he had family. And in May 2006, at age 28, started classes at Parkland, a community college. But Sam was still struggling. And to help me understand some of what he was going through, Sam gave me permission to talk to his VA therapist. His name is Tim Kohlbecker. He runs a PTSD clinic serving veterans in Illinois and parts of Indiana.
那天之后，萨姆得到了帮助。他开始了 PTSD 治疗，从军队退役，搬到了他有亲戚居住的香槟市。2006 年 5 月，28 岁的他开始在帕克兰社区学院上课。但萨姆仍在挣扎。为了帮助我理解他正在经历的一些事情，萨姆允许我与他的 VA 治疗师交谈。他的名字叫蒂姆·科尔贝克。他在伊利诺伊州和印第安纳州的部分地区经营一家服务于退伍军人的 PTSD 诊所。
And he explained what can happen to soldiers in combat this way. Imagine you're in a room with 10 identical chairs. You're told to sit in one of them, and you get an electric shock. The next day, you're told to sit in the same chair again, and you get shocked again. The third day, you wise up. You're not sitting in that chair anymore.
他这样解释士兵在战斗中可能发生的情况。想象你在一个有 10 把相同椅子的房间里。有人让你坐在其中一把上，然后你遭到电击。第二天，有人让你再坐回同一把椅子上，你又遭到了电击。第三天，你学聪明了。你再也不会坐在那把椅子上了。
I say, how about one of these other chairs? And you're looking around at those and you're thinking, no, no. They may all be wired up.
我说，那这些椅子中的其他椅子呢？你环顾四周，心想，不，不。它们可能都带电。
Because they all look exactly the same as the chair?
因为它们看起来和那把椅子完全一样？
They all look the same. It all seems the same. It's the same thing. So you've developed a fear of all of them. Well, that happens with somebody in a combat situation, where you are on full alert all the time. You never know who the enemy is. You don't know when they're going to pop up. So you develop an anxiety, or a fear, or an avoidance of all.
它们看起来都一样。看起来全都一样。都是同样的东西。所以你对它们全部产生了恐惧。好吧，在战斗情况下，一个人会时刻保持高度警惕。你永远不知道谁是敌人。你不知道他们什么时候会跳出来。所以你对一切都产生了一种焦虑、恐惧或回避。
Sam's college campus wasn't exactly a hotbed of Arab and Muslim culture. But for Sam, it didn't take much. Just the site of an Arab man in a beard could trigger his anxiety.
萨姆的大学校园并不是那种阿拉伯和穆斯林文化集中的地方。但对萨姆来说，这不需要太多触点。只要看到一个留胡子的阿拉伯男人就能触发他的焦虑。
I was just like, oh, man, there's Muslims everywhere. If I saw one of them, I would just walk the other way, find another way to get to wherever I was going to.
我当时就想，哦，伙计，到处都是穆斯林。如果我看到其中一个，我会直接走另一条路，找另一条路去我要去的地方。
Like, literally turn around and--?
就像，真的掉头然后——？
Yeah. Yeah, because I wasn't sure if I got too close to the guy, what would happen?
是的。是的，因为我不确定如果我离那个人太近，会发生什么？
One day he almost did get too close. In the hallway of a campus building, he spotted this guy, Middle-Eastern looking, with a long beard.
有一天他差点真的走得太近了。在校园大楼的走廊里，他发现了这个家伙，长相中东，留着长胡子。
As I saw him there and I thought, oh, man, there's another one of them. And it's just like an instantaneous rush of anxiety and adrenaline, and I was like what do I do? And, of course, the thought of ridding him from that situation was an option. And--
当我看到他在那儿，我想，哦，伙计，又是一个他们的人。那是一种瞬间的焦虑和肾上腺素激增，我当时想我该怎么办？当然，摆脱那种处境是一个选择。然后——
What do you mean?
你什么意思？
Well, you know, just choke him out or take him in for questioning, or something. But I'm like, what am I doing? This isn't a war zone. Why am I even thinking this nonsense? I'm not armed. I'm not a killer. I mean, I never was, prior to the war. And all  I [UNINTELLIGIBLE] and I was just like, you know, wait. Stop. Stand here a minute and think about it.
嗯，你知道，直接把他勒死或者带去审讯，或者类似的事情。但我心想，我在做什么？这不是战区。我为什么会想这种荒唐的事情？我没带武器。我不是杀手。我是说，战前我从来都不是。我就这样 [听不清] 我当时想，你知道，等等。停下。站在这里想一分钟。
You know, I want to say that I felt good that nothing happened, but at the same time I just felt terrible. It was like, what have I become? I mean, I didn't have any, you know, notions or thoughts about Muslims prior to joining the Army, but I was, like, why am I not like that anymore? And I was like, what can I do to get back to the way I was? A better person. I sat and thought, and I looked up from the chair I was sitting in and I saw a little poster on a bulletin board that said, "Learn about Islam. Join the Muslim Student Association. It meets on Thursdays." And I thought, you know what? Maybe that'd be good for me. So I went to this Muslim Student Association meeting the next Thursday.
你知道，我想说，没发生什么让我感觉很好，但与此同时，我感到非常可怕。就像是，我变成了什么？我是说，我加入军队之前没有任何关于穆斯林的偏见或想法，但我当时想，为什么我现在不是那样了？我想，我能做些什么才能变回原来的样子？变回一个更好的人。我坐在那里思考，从椅子上抬头看，我看到了公告栏上的一张小海报，上面写着：“了解伊斯兰教。加入穆斯林学生协会。每周四开会。”我想，你知道吗？也许那对我会有好处。所以我参加了那个周四的穆斯林学生协会会议。
Now, before I tell you what happened at that meeting, some background on the Muslim Student Association at Parkland College. You've already met the founder and president, Yousif Radeef. He was the guy speaking Arabic on the holiday video. He also happens to be the bearded man who Sam wanted to jump in the hallway that day. And he's an Iraqi, though his family left Iraq when he was 10 and moved to Jordan, and then the United Arab Emirates before coming to Illinois three years ago.
现在，在我告诉你那个会议上发生了什么之前，先介绍一下帕克兰学院穆斯林学生协会的背景。你已经见过创始人兼主席尤西夫·拉迪夫了。他就是那个在节日视频里说阿拉伯语的人。他恰好也是萨姆那天在走廊里想攻击的那个胡子男人。他是个伊拉克人，不过他 10 岁时全家离开了伊拉克搬到了约旦，然后搬到了阿拉伯联合酋长国，三年前来到伊利诺伊州。
Yousif was 17 when he got here. And other Muslims warned him to be careful what he said, that as a Muslim from the Arab world, anything he did might be viewed with suspicion.
尤西夫刚到这里时 17 岁。其他穆斯林警告他说话要小心，作为来自阿拉伯世界的穆斯林，他做的任何事情都可能被怀疑。
The first six months was like the darkest months of my experience in the United States, because I did not have the chance to say what I wanted to say. I did not behave like myself or the guy who I was. I have had to be from a guy who talks about my religion to a guy who advised not to talk about it. So it was a really sudden change. It was so bad, it was so bad. But it got better. I'm glad that it got better.
前六个月是我在美国经历中最黑暗的几个月，因为我没有机会说我想说的话。我没有表现得像我自己，或者以前的那个我。我不得不从一个谈论自己宗教的人变成一个被建议不要谈论它的人。所以那是一个非常突然的改变。太糟糕了，真的太糟糕了。但后来好转了。我很高兴情况好转了。
It got better mostly because Yousif made it better. He decided he didn't want to hide who he was or what he thought. So when he got to Parkland College, he threw himself into campus life. He joined clubs and got elected to student government, and wasn't afraid to say that he opposed the Iraq War. And he started the school's first official chapter of the Muslim Student Association.
情况好转主要是因为尤西夫让它变得更好。他决定不想隐藏自己的身份或想法。所以当他到达帕克兰学院时，他全身心投入到校园生活中。他加入了社团，当选为学生会成员，并且不怕说出他反对伊拉克战争。他还创办了学校第一个正式的穆斯林学生协会分部。
Yousif wanted this particular chapter to be different than other Muslim student groups he had heard about. One of his main goals was to reach out to students who weren't Muslim, especially the ones who had a bad impression of his faith.
尤西夫希望这个分部能与他听说过的其他穆斯林学生团体有所不同。他的主要目标之一是接触那些非穆斯林学生，特别是那些对他的信仰有不好印象的学生。
Somebody have to speak up. Somebody have to tell everybody that what they see in the news, what they hear on the radio, what they read in the magazines and the newspapers is not really true. They only see violence with the name of Islam. So, it's like, OK, it's a religion of violence. And I have heard a lot of people saying this exact quote.
总得有人站出来说话。总得有人告诉大家，他们在新闻中看到的、广播里听到的、杂志和报纸上读到的那些并不一定是真的。他们只看到了以伊斯兰教名义发生的暴力。所以，看起来就像是，好的，这是一种暴力的宗教。我听到很多人说过这句原话。
For Yousif, having a guy like Sam, someone filled with negative feelings about Muslims, just walk into an MSA meeting was actually kind of a dream scenario. It was like he'd hit the jackpot. Though, Yousif, going above and beyond the call of duty when it comes to bridging the cultural divide, chose this analogy.
对尤西夫来说，能有像萨姆这样的人——一个充满对穆斯林的负面情绪的人——走进 MSA 会议，简直是梦想成真的情景。就像他中了大奖一样。虽然，尤西夫在跨越文化鸿沟方面超越了职责范围，他选择了这个比喻。
What would a kid feel like on Christmas day, when he get the presents he want and some extra? I felt more, more than great. Great is a small word when I hear that he said, he was a soldier, he had this thing going on, and he came here to change his mind, and all by himself. Nobody urged him to do so. I was super excited, super excited.
一个孩子在圣诞节那天，得到他想要的礼物还有额外奖励时会是什么感觉？我感到非常、非常棒。“棒”这个词太小了，当我听到他说他曾是一名士兵，他经历了那些事情，然后他亲自来到这里改变主意，没有人强迫他这样做。我超级兴奋，超级兴奋。
I tell you what, that first day I was in there, I was sweating and trembling and just like, my god, what am I doing?
我告诉你，第一天我在那里的时候，我全身冒汗、颤抖，心想，天哪，我在做什么？
There were about 10, maybe 12 students at the meeting, including Yousif, who Sam recognized instantly.
会议上有大约 10 个，也许 12 个学生，包括尤西夫，萨姆一眼就认出了他。
I walked in the door and I saw that same bearded guy that I'd been behind the week before. And thought, oh, wow, this is something here. And I saw a lot of females on one side of the room, and the males on the other. And just thought, I know I'm not supposed to sit by the women or something-- that's what they told us in Iraq-- but that's where the door is and I need to be near that door. And I kind of sat there.
我走进门，看到了上周我在他身后的那个胡子男。心想，哦，哇，这下有意思了。我看到房间一边坐着许多女性，另一边坐着男性。心想，我知道我不应该坐在女性旁边什么的——那是我们在伊拉克被告知的——但门就在那里，我需要靠近门口。我就坐在了那里。
I know I was-- my hands were clenched on the desk, and I was just trembling and sweating and just felt like I was about to have some sort of major anxiety attack, just because it was the first time I'd been outnumbered by Arabs and Muslims since I'd been in Iraq. So I felt like, hey, I'm back in Iraq again. But I had to keep telling myself, no, no you're not. You're sitting here. You're in a classroom, in college here. You're here voluntarily. You're here at a meeting.
我知道我当时——我的手紧紧抓着书桌，我在颤抖和流汗，感觉就像要发生某种严重的焦虑发作，只是因为这是我从伊拉克回来后第一次被阿拉伯人和穆斯林的人数所包围。所以我感觉像是，嘿，我又回到伊拉克了。但我不得不不断告诉自己，不，不，你没有。你坐在那里。你是在教室里，是在大学里。你是自愿在这里的。你是来参加会议的。
I remember the very first day when he came, it was very shocking for us.
我记得他来的第一天，对我们来说非常震惊。
That's [? Manal, ?] an MSA member from Morocco. Sam wasn't the only one in the room having a hard time that day. [? Manal ?], and her sister [? Lahmie ?], told me they were uncomfortable, too. Only for them, the reason was Sam.
那是 [? Manal ?]，一位来自摩洛哥的 MSA 成员。那天房间里感到难受的不止萨姆一个人。[? Manal ?] 和她的妹妹 [? Lahmie ?] 告诉我，她们也感到不自在。对她们来说，原因就是萨姆。
We ?] were really saying, what was he doing there? Is he there as a spy? Or to record all the information that we're saying? He was asking a lot of questions at the beginning, like where are you from? And how do you spell your name? And things like that. It just made you a little skeptical.
我们当时确实在说，他来这里干什么？他是间谍吗？或者来记录我们所说的所有信息？他刚开始问了很多问题，比如你来自哪里？你的名字怎么拼？之类的。这让人有点怀疑。
I know somebody asked me, they're like, so why are you here? Not in a condescending manner. It was just, why are you here? What do you want to learn from this? And all I said was, like, I'm doing this for therapy. And they just looked at me like I was kind of crazy. And they're like, what do you mean? And I said, well, I was in the war and I just want to change my perspective on why I feel the way I feel about your religion and people.
我知道有人问我，他们就像是，那么你为什么在这里？语气并不傲慢。只是，你为什么在这里？你想从中学到什么？我只是说，我这样做是为了治疗。他们看我就像看个疯子一样。他们说，你什么意思？我说，嗯，我参加过战争，我只是想改变我对为什么我会有这种对你们宗教和人民的感觉的看法。
You said that the first day?
你第一天就说了这个？
Yeah. Yeah, and some of them were like, oh, man, we've got to watch out for this guy. They were probably more concerned about me than I was concerned about them at that point.
是的。是的，他们中有些人就像是，哦，伙计，我们要提防这个家伙。在那一点上，他们可能比我关心他们更关心我。
The first ?] time he was talking about himself--
他第一次谈论他自己时——
[? Lahmie, ?] [? Manal's ?] sister.
[? Lahmie ?]，[? Manal ?] 的妹妹。
He wasn't showing any regrets or any feelings about his experience in Iraq. And that was some kind of hurting for us, because of we do have feelings for what is happening in Iraq.
他没有表现出任何后悔或对他经历的伊拉克的感受。这对我们来说有点伤害，因为我们对伊拉克正在发生的事情确实有感情。
[? Manal ?] told me about one young woman at the meeting who was from Iraq.
[? Manal ?] 告诉我会议上有一个来自伊拉克的年轻女子。
And ?] he asked that very girl from Iraq, how was the situation before? And she just told him, it was much better than now. She had some family members that died in the recent Iraq War. It was very hurting for her.
他问那个来自伊拉克的女孩，以前的情况怎么样？她只是告诉他，比现在好得多。她在最近的伊拉克战争中失去了一些家庭成员。这对她来说非常受伤。
The meeting ended. And sometime later, Sam and Yousif ended up running into each other on campus.
会议结束了。后来，萨姆和尤西夫在校园里偶然遇见了。
And I did pretty well. I shook the guy's hand, which I never thought I'd do after the first time I saw the guy. And what really struck me was when he said, I'm from Iraq. And I just froze. I was like, oh my gosh, I'm standing here with an Iraqi. I was like, wow. Not only was I with all these Muslims and everything today, but I stood there and talked to an Iraqi and shook his hand.
我表现得很好。我和那个人握了手，第一次见到他时我从没想过我会这么做。真正触动我的是他说他是来自伊拉克的。我直接愣住了。我想，天哪，我竟然和一个伊拉克人站在一起。我想，哇。今天我不但和所有这些穆斯林待在一起，而且我还站在那里和一个伊拉克人交谈并握了他的手。
I went home and I called the therapist and I was like, I sat down with a bunch of Muslims this week. And we was like, oh, no, what happened?
我回家后给治疗师打电话说，这周我和一群穆斯林坐在一起了。他问，哦，不，发生了什么？
I still remember the day he told me he joined the Muslim Student Association. I almost fell off my chair.
我仍然记得他告诉我他加入穆斯林学生协会的那一天。我差点从椅子上掉下来。
What Sam had done was not the course of action his therapist had recommended. He'd basically cooked up for himself an extreme version of a pretty standard treatment for trauma, exposure therapy, where you re-experience a traumatic event as a way of recovering from it.
萨姆所做的事情并不是他的治疗师推荐的行动方案。他基本上为自己炮制了一种非常标准的创伤治疗方法的极端版本：暴露疗法，即你通过重温创伤事件来从中恢复。
What you're trying to ultimately do is take what we call a hot memory-- that's a traumatic memory that still owns him, so to speak-- and turn it into just a bad memory. Everybody's got bad memories and we can live with bad memories. You're not going to make it go away. You just want to desensitize it so that it's not having such an intrusive effect in their lives.
你最终试图做的是把你所说的“热记忆”——那种仍然困扰他的创伤性记忆——变成一种普通的糟糕记忆。每个人都有糟糕的记忆，我们可以带着它们生活。你无法让它们消失。你只是想让它脱敏，这样它就不会对他们的生活产生那么大的干扰。
The problem with what Sam did, and why Kohlbecker says he'd never counsel a patient to do it, is that it wasn't gradual. It was like he jumped into the deep end not knowing if he could swim. But his doctor thought he could handle it, so Sam kept going back.
萨姆所做的事情的问题，以及为什么科尔贝克说他永远不会建议病人这样做，是它不是循序渐进的。就像他不知道自己会不会游泳就跳进了深水区一样。但他的医生认为他能应付，所以萨姆不断回去。
I know it was extremely difficult for him to make himself stay in the room, but it got gradually easier and easier and easier.
我知道让他强迫自己待在房间里是非常困难的，但它变得越来越容易了。
Probably by the fifth or sixth week, I'd move away from the seat by the door and I start talking to the people and I'd ask questions. Like, why have I always heard this about whatever aspect of Islam? To try and understand why what happened in the name of Islam happened when I was in Iraq. And they'd be like, well, that's because that guy is totally nuts. That's why. I'm like, that makes sense.
大概在第五或第六周，我从门口的座位上移开，开始和人们交谈，并提问。比如，为什么我总是听到关于伊斯兰教的某个方面的这些说法？试着理解为什么我在伊拉克时发生的以伊斯兰教名义的事情会发生。他们会说，嗯，那是因为那个家伙完全疯了。这就是原因。我心想，那说得通。
I grew up here in the US of A-- what are we? Pretty much a Christian nation, and we got a lot of Christian nuts out here. I was like, yeah, I could see. I guess they're entitled to have their wackos, too.
我在美国长大的——我们是什么？基本上是一个基督教国家，我们这里有很多疯狂的基督徒。我心想，是的，我看得出来。我想他们也有权拥有他们的疯子。
As the school year went on, some of the other students in the MSA started noticing something about Sam. The only non-Muslim in their group had become one of its most active members.
随着学年的进行，MSA 中的其他一些学生开始注意到萨姆的一些事情。他们团体中唯一的非穆斯林已成为最活跃的成员之一。
Whenever we had meetings, he was the first person to come and we would always find him at the door, waiting for the other members.
每当我们要开会时，他是第一个到来的人，我们总会发现他在门口等着其他成员。
[? Manal ?] had stopped wondering if Sam was a spy. His dedication had won her over.
[? Manal ?] 已经不再怀疑萨姆是否是间谍了。他的奉献精神赢得了她的认可。
And he also volunteered, almost always, to sit in a table that we would set in the college center to outreach other people and get them to know about what we really believe in, and that we're not all terrorists, things to dispel the misconceptions that people had. And it was him that was doing this job from times to others.
而且他几乎总是自愿坐在我们设置在学院中心的桌子上，向其他人进行外联，让他们了解我们真正相信什么，我们并非都是恐怖分子，这些是为了消除人们有的误解。是他在做这项工作。
Did you catch that? Sam actually sat at a table on campus, representing Muslim students.
你听到了吗？萨姆真的坐在校园的一张桌子旁，代表穆斯林学生。
It had a really good impact on everyone. He just showed us he was very devoted to the work he was doing.
这对每个人都有很好的影响。他向我们展示了他非常致力于他正在做的工作。
The adviser to the MSA, Dennis Kaczor, noticed another change in Sam.
MSA 的顾问丹尼斯·卡佐尔注意到了萨姆的另一个变化。
I began to find out that Yousif and him were doing things, going different places and hanging out.
我开始发现尤西夫和他经常在一起，去不同的地方，待在一起。
And they weren't talking about the Iraq war, either.
他们也没在谈论伊拉克战争。
He said he's an Iraq war veteran. And he knows I'm a [UNINTELLIGIBLE] Iraqi. This is one of things that got us involved together, one of them. But the most thing that got us involved is probably magic, the magic tricks.
他说他是伊拉克战争老兵。他知道我是个 [听不清] 伊拉克人。这是我们交往的原因之一。但让我们走到一起的最主要原因可能是魔术，魔术戏法。
That's right, magic tricks. See, Sam's a magician, a detail that might not be relevant were  it not for the fact that Yousif loves magic. And one day, in an MSA seeming, Sam took out a deck of cards.
没错，魔术戏法。你看，萨姆是个魔术师，如果不是因为尤西夫喜欢魔术，这个细节可能就不相关了。有一天，在 MSA 会议上，萨姆掏出了一副牌。
Magicians, if they have nothing to do, they just practice on their cards while they're listening in a class, I believe. So he came in with his cards in his hands and he's trying to shuffle them, flip them, do the tricks. I saw him, I was like, ooh, that's cool. I asked him a couple of questions and he answered me back.
魔术师，如果没什么事可做，我相信他们在课堂上听讲时就会练习他们的牌。所以他手里拿着牌进来了，试着洗牌、翻牌、变魔术。我看到了，我想，喔，那很酷。我问了他几个问题，他回答了我。
And soon they were spending time together.
很快他们就在一起度过时光了。
[CARDS SHUFFLING] Practicing magic tricks.
[洗牌声] 练习魔术戏法。
What I'm going to going do, I'm going to take your card, and without looking at it, I'm just going to insert it down there.
我要做的，我要拿走你的牌，在不看它的情况下，我就把它插进去。
Taking their first car ride.
第一次坐车。
It was like, wow, I'm actually sitting in the car with an Iraqi.
当时感觉是，哇，我竟然和一个伊拉克人坐在车里。
Were you driving me or was I driving you?
是你开车载我还是我开车载你？
You were driving. And I think I said it out loud. I was like, I can't believe I'm sitting in here without a gun, because every time I'd been in a vehicle with an Iraqi, I was armed.
是你开的。我想我大声说了出来。我说，我不敢相信我竟然在没有枪的情况下坐在这里，因为每次我和伊拉克人在车里时，我都是全副武装。
Like any friends, they were there for each other. Yousif helped Sam fix his roof, and Sam gave Yousif advice on the best way to approach Americans when raising money for the MSA.
像任何朋友一样，他们互相帮助。尤西夫帮萨姆修了屋顶，萨姆为尤西夫在为 MSA 筹款时接触美国人的最佳方式提供了建议。
Sam told me, when we go inside, don't tell them it's the Muslim Student Association.
萨姆告诉我说，当我们进去时，不要告诉他们是穆斯林学生协会。
Don't tell them we're from the Muslim Student Association, just say MSA.
不要告诉他们我们来自穆斯林学生协会，只说 MSA。
Because we didn't want them to say, oh, wait, I'm not supporting that kind of organization. It's probably al Qaeda or something.
因为我们不想让他们说，哦，等等，我不支持那种组织。那可能是基地组织什么的。
And then, last April, came Sam and Yousif's most ambitious collaboration.
然后，去年四月，萨姆和尤西夫进行了他们最雄心勃勃的合作。
WCIA-3 News at 10:00.
WCIA-3 10 点新闻。
Well, some runners in Champaign were busy fighting the negative image of Islam today through exercise. Parkland College's Muslim Student organization held a 5K run this morning. Runners from all over the country participated for the $1,000 top prize.
好的，今天香槟市的一些跑步者正忙着通过运动来对抗伊斯兰教的负面形象。帕克兰学院穆斯林学生组织今天上午举办了一场 5 公里跑步活动。来自全国各地的跑步者参加了比赛，争夺 1000 美元的头奖。
The 5K run was the MSA's biggest project, and it never would have happened without Sam. He volunteered to organize the race, and spent months planning and publicizing it. And in the end, it was just what Yousif had hoped for, a positive event for the whole community that just happened to be sponsored by Muslims. It was a big day. And to top it off, after the race, Yousif invited Sam to play in a soccer game with a group of Muslim students from the state university.
5 公里跑是 MSA 最大的项目，如果没有萨姆，它绝不会发生。他自愿组织这场比赛，花了几个月的时间进行计划和宣传。最终，这正是尤西夫所希望的，这是一场为整个社区举办的积极活动，恰好是由穆斯林赞助的。那是重要的一天。最重要的是，赛后，尤西夫邀请萨姆与一群来自州立大学的穆斯林学生进行了一场足球比赛。
A year earlier just the idea of being on a playing field, surrounded by Muslim men he didn't know, would have made Sam anxious.
一年前，仅仅是身处一个被他不认识的穆斯林男人包围的运动场上的想法，就会让萨姆感到焦虑。
I considered that particular day to just be a big milestone in overcoming all the PTSD and everything. Because one, I was kind of like in a gladiator pit full of Muslims, and--
我把那天视为克服 PTSD 和所有一切的一个重要里程碑。因为第一，我感觉就像在满是穆斯林的角斗场里，而且——
Totally.
完全同意。
But just to show you how complicated their situation was, at the same time Sam was realizing how far he'd come, Yousif was having the opposite experience, getting a reminder of how far apart their two worlds still were. And I guess I should add that Sam wasn't with us when Yousif told me this part of the story.
但为了让你了解他们的情况有多复杂，在萨姆意识到他走了多远的同时，尤西夫却有了相反的经历，提醒他他们的两个世界仍然相隔多远。我想我应该补充说，当尤西夫告诉我故事的这一部分时，萨姆不在我们身边。
We got there, we played and people asked me who he was. So I told him he was Sam from the MSA, Muslim Student Association of Parkland, as you know, American and an Iraq War veteran. And some people started being suspicious. What is he doing in the MSA? He should not be in the MSA. MSA only for Muslims. He's an Iraq War veteran, don't think he's spying on us? All these things that made me feel sick to a certain point.
我们到了那里，我们玩了，人们问我他是谁。所以我告诉他们他是 MSA 的萨姆，帕克兰的穆斯林学生协会，你知道，美国人和伊拉克战争老兵。有些人开始怀疑。他在 MSA 干什么？他不应该在 MSA。MSA 只给穆斯林。他是伊拉克战争老兵，不觉得他在监视我们吗？所有这些事情让我感到有些恶心。
What did you say to them?
你对他们说什么了？
I didn't reply back. I just kept quiet. We have hang out for, I don't know, six months by then. And we were just regular friends, go out, talk, hang out at Parkland College. I kind of don't feel he was an Iraq War veteran anymore.
我没回话。我只是保持沉默。到那时我们已经相处了，不知道，六个月了。我们只是普通朋友，出去玩、交谈、在帕克兰学院聚会。我有点不觉得他是伊拉克战争老兵了。
This is just some footage from the turret of a tank.
这只是一些从坦克炮塔拍摄的画面。
When I went to Champaign, I took Sam up on his offer to play me some of the videotape he'd shot in Iraq. After all the talking we'd done about the war, it was interesting to actually see him there. There were shots of Sam him driving his Humvee, and on guard duty, and a lot of funny scenes, off-duty soldiers just goofing around. Like these guys, amusing themselves during down time by shocking themselves with tasers.
当我去香槟市时，我接受了萨姆的提议，让他给我看一些他在伊拉克拍摄的录像带。在我们聊了这么多关于战争的话题后，看到他当时的样子很有意思。有一些萨姆开着悍马、站岗的镜头，还有很多滑稽的场景，休假的士兵们只是在乱玩。就像这些人，在闲暇时间通过用电击枪电击自己来自娱自乐。
C'mon, you can take it.
来吧，你能承受的。
[TASER CRACKLING]
[电击枪噼啪声]
Ah. [BLEEP] Ah, [BLEEP].
啊。[BLEEP] 啊，[BLEEP]。
Yousif was in the room with us. He'd come to Sam's house to meet me that day, and he'd also been curious to see the video. I kept thinking how weird it must have been for him to be watching some of the footage, even just seeing Sam in Yousif's country, wearing camouflage and sunglasses and carrying a rifle was a little startling.
尤西夫和我们在一起。那天他来到萨姆家见我，他也很好奇地想看录像。我一直想，对他来说看这些镜头一定有多奇怪，即使只是看到萨姆在尤西夫的国家，穿着迷彩服和太阳镜，扛着步枪也让人有点吃惊。
In one shot, Sam tells the camera that there isn't much to see in Iraq, besides trash and filth and the scum of the earth. And then there was this scene, a bunch of soldiers standing around telling jokes to a guy named Hamsa, their Iraqi translator.
在一个镜头中，萨姆对着镜头说，在伊拉克没什么好看的，除了垃圾、污秽和地球上的人渣。然后是这个场景，一群士兵站在那里对着一个叫汉姆萨的人讲笑话，他是他们的伊拉克翻译。
Hey, Hamsa, you know what the difference is between an Iraqi and a human? Everything.
嘿，汉姆萨，你知道伊拉克人和人类的区别吗？一切。
The next one was hard to hear, So Sam repeated it.
下一个很难听清，所以萨姆重复了一遍。
The next kid here, he's saying, "What's the difference between a dead Iraqi in the road and a dead skunk in the road?" The punchline is "There's tire skid marks on the road before the dead skunk."
这里的下一个孩子说，“路上的死伊拉克人和路上的死臭鼬有什么区别？”笑话的梗是“死臭鼬之前路面上有轮胎刹车痕迹”。
And then came Sam's joke.
然后轮到萨姆的笑话了。
Hey, why do Iraqi men wear mustaches? So they can look like their mothers.
嘿，为什么伊拉克男人要留胡子？这样他们看起来就像他们的母亲。
I glanced over at Yousif to see how he was reacting. I was feeling incredibly uncomfortable. But when I asked Yousif how he was feeling, he said even though he knew some Iraqis would be offended by the jokes, he wasn't. He didn't blame Sam for talking this way.
我看了看尤西夫，想看看他的反应。我感到极其不舒服。但当我问尤西夫他感觉如何时，他说尽管他知道有些伊拉克人会因为这些笑话而感到被冒犯，但他没有。他不怪萨姆那样说话。
He was just like any other American soldier down in the battlefield.
他就像战场上任何其他美国士兵一样。
Do you think they're all like that?
你认为他们都那样吗？
I would assume so. Or worse. Probably he was the best soldier [? in mood ?] back then, being this way. It's a battlefield. I mean, it's not a joke. It is a serious thing. So I do not feel different from the videos. I don't know.
我假定是的。或者更糟。可能他当时是最好的士兵 [? in mood ?]，就是那样。这是战场。我的意思是，这不是开玩笑。这是一件严肃的事情。所以我对视频没有异样的感觉。我不知道。
But more than anything, Yousif says, the Sam in the video just wasn't the Sam he knows. They are two different guys. And when I talk to Sam, that's basically the same thing he says. The war changed him.
但最重要的是，尤西夫说，视频里的萨姆只是不是他认识的那个萨姆。他们是两个人。当我跟萨姆谈话时，他说的基本上也是一样。战争改变了他。
You know, somebody listening to this right now might say, well, I would never say Iraqi men wear mustaches so they can look like their mothers. But you know what? Can you honestly say that without being in the situation? Because I sit here now and say, well, I'd never say that, but that's what happened. That's just how you get through it.
你知道，现在听这个的人可能会说，好吧，我永远不会说伊拉克男人留胡子是为了看起来像他们的母亲。但你知道吗？你不身处那种情况，你能诚实地说吗？因为我现在坐在这里说，好吧，我永远不会那样说，但那就是发生的事情。这就是你度过难关的方式。
It's obviously not something that I'm proud of, or probably most people are proud of, but you don't care that it's perceived as bigoted or just inhumane. It doesn't matter to you because you're in this situation. They were trying to kill you. And when somebody is trying to kill you, everything you thought you believed up until the point when bullets start flying by your head, changes. It didn't bring out the very worst in me, but it is the worst I'm ever going to be in my life. I can tell you that.
这显然不是我引以为豪的事情，或者可能大多数人引以为豪的事情，但你并不在乎它被视为偏执或不人道。这对你来说没关系，因为你处在这种情况下。他们试图杀你。当有人试图杀你时，在你被子弹击中头部之前你认为你相信的一切，都会改变。它并没有带出我身上最糟糕的一面，但这是我一生中最糟糕的表现。我可以告诉你这一点。
Sam told me later he was actually a little nervous showing Yousif the videos, but just a little. He trusted Yousif, trusted their friendship, which is a long way to come from wanting to take him down in a hallway. It was only by the sheer force of will that Sam even went to the Muslim Student Association in the first place. And to do it, he had to overlook every instinct he had telling him to run the other way.
萨姆后来告诉我，他给尤西夫看录像时其实有点紧张，但只是一点点。他信任尤西夫，信任他们的友谊，从想在走廊里干掉他，这已经走了很长的路。仅仅凭借纯粹的意志力，萨姆才去了穆斯林学生协会。为了做到这一点，他必须忽略他所有的直觉，那些告诉他往相反方向逃跑的直觉。
And then he had to meet someone like Yousif, who welcomed him, ignoring anything Sam might have done in the past. When you consider what it took for Sam to overcome his hatred, it's no wonder it happens so rarely.
然后他必须遇到像尤西夫这样的人，他欢迎他，忽略了萨姆过去可能做的任何事情。当你考虑到萨姆克服仇恨需要付出什么时，难怪它很少发生。
Lisa Pollak. She is one of the producers of our show. Last fall, Yousif move to the University of Illinois where he's studying molecular and cell biology. He plans to be a dentist. Sam is at Eastern Illinois University, where he is studying geography.
丽莎·波拉克。她是我们的节目制作人之一。去年秋天，尤西夫搬到了伊利诺伊大学，学习分子和细胞生物学。他计划成为一名牙医。萨姆在东伊利诺伊大学，学习地理。
Coming up, what to do if the very reasonable, very persuasive voice inside your head tells you to drink, to smoke, to stop ironing that skirt. That's in a minute, from Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International, when our program continues.
接下来，如果脑海中非常合理、非常有说服力的声音告诉你喝酒、抽烟、不要再熨那条裙子，该怎么办。这一内容将在一分钟后播出，来自芝加哥公共广播电台和国际公共广播电台，我们的节目继续。
It's This American Life , I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we choose a theme, bring you a variety of different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's show, The Devil Inside Me. We have stories of people battling things inside themselves, impulses and thoughts they would rather not have. We have arrived at Act Two of our show.
这是《美国生活》，我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周，我们都会选择一个主题，为您带来各种不同类型的关于该主题的故事。今天的节目，《内心的恶魔》。我们有关于那些与内心事物作斗争的人的故事，那些他们宁愿没有的冲动和想法。我们的节目已经到了第二幕。
Act two, Vox Diaboli. Of course, we all have things inside ourselves that we want to fight. 12-step programs and self-help books and organized religion would not do such a thriving business if this were not so common. But sometimes, the voice in one's head really does seem like a voice. Addicts talk about this a lot. This is the voice of having one drink, you know, just one drink. You deserve it, you can handle it. Just one drink.
第二幕，魔鬼的声音。当然，我们每个人内心都有想要对抗的事物。如果这不是如此普遍，12 步计划、自助书籍和有组织的宗教就不会有这么兴旺的业务了。但有时，脑海中的声音真的看起来就像一个声音。成瘾者经常谈论这个。这就是那种喝一杯的声音，你知道，就喝一杯。你应得的，你可以处理的。就喝一杯。
Well, one of our producers, Nancy Updike, started asking around about whether people felt like they were under a spell of an inner voice like this. And it was like people had been waiting all their lives for somebody to ask them this question. She heard from serial cheaters, and road ragers, and move-aholics, a guy who obsessively buys too much food to the point where he goes into debt, people compulsive in ways that she had never heard of.
好吧，我们的一位制作人南希·厄普代克开始询问人们是否觉得他们处于这种内心声音的咒语之下。就好像人们一生都在等待有人问他们这个问题。她听到了连环出轨者、路怒症患者、购物狂的故事，一个强迫性购买太多食物直到负债的人，人们有着她从未听说过的强迫方式。
Here are some of them. A quick warning to listeners, there's nothing explicit in here, but one of the people in here does acknowledge the existence of sex.
这里有一些。给听众一个小警告，这里没有什么露骨的内容，但其中一个人承认了性的存在。
I certainly know voice you're talking about.
我当然知道你在说哪种声音。
The voice is irresistible, always. I'm in the thrall of that voice.
那声音总是不可抗拒的。我受制于那个声音。
Totally out of control. It's got this life of its own, and I can't tame it anymore.
完全失控了。它有自己的生命，我再也无法驯服它了。
Up until recently, that voice has made me a very poor man.
直到最近，那个声音让我成了一个非常贫穷的人。
I actually have a name for the voice. I call it Stan. Stan is the guy who tells me to have the extra glass of wine. Stan is the guy who tells me to smoke.
我实际上给这个声音起了一个名字。我叫它斯坦。斯坦是那个告诉我再喝一杯酒的人。斯坦是那个告诉我抽烟的人。
I remember somehow realizing just how finely calibrated the voice was to every nuance, every part of my feelings, including the feeling that I didn't want to smoke cigarettes. And it's just like, might as well have another cigarette, because this is it. Tomorrow you're going to quit.
我记得不知怎么地意识到那个声音是多么精准地调整到每一个细微之处，我感受的每一部分，包括我不想抽烟的感觉。就像是，不妨再抽一支烟，因为就是这样。明天你会戒掉的。
Oh yeah, my voice can pull up statistics, like, obesity is a killer.
哦，是的，我的声音可以列出统计数据，比如，肥胖是杀手。
So the voice would also say, well, it's not that many beers. Because, in fact, if you're thin enough, you actually don't have to drink all that much to get high.
所以那个声音也会说，好吧，啤酒没那么多。因为，事实上，如果你足够瘦，你其实不需要喝那么多就能兴奋。
Go back to bed for five minutes, just five minutes. Five more minutes, close your eyes, you'll feel great.
再睡五分钟，就五分钟。再睡五分钟，闭上眼睛，你会感觉很棒。
And then tomorrow something would happen, and there's a good reason to smoke that day. And then it was, oh you already smoked today, so today's not the day you are going to quit, so smoke another cigarette.
然后明天会发生什么，那一天有充分的理由抽烟。然后就是，哦，你今天已经抽了，所以今天不是你要戒烟的日子，所以再抽一支烟。
And then I'll get up five minutes later and it'll be like, eh, I mean, you don't need to iron a skirt. Do you really need to iron the skirt? If you need to iron the skirt, do you need to be wearing the skirt? Maybe you could wear a different skirt, and then you could sleep for 10 more minutes. And that seems like a reasonable negotiation.
然后我会五分钟后再起床，就好像，呃，我是说，你不需要熨裙子。你真的需要熨裙子吗？如果你需要熨裙子，你需要穿这条裙子吗？也许你可以穿另一条裙子，然后你可以多睡 10 分钟。这看起来是一个合理的谈判。
One of the things I do, that the voice came up with, is when I binge and purge, you never can be sure how much you got back up. The voice came up with the idea that, if I put a coffee can on a scale and adjusted the weight to include the weight of the coffee can, and weighed all my food before I ate it, and then threw up in the same coffee can, I could judge by the weight how much came up.
我所做的事情之一，那是那个声音想出来的，就是当我暴饮暴食和催吐时，你永远无法确定你吐出了多少。那个声音想出了一个主意，如果我把一个咖啡罐放在秤上，调整重量以包括咖啡罐的重量，并在吃之前称量我所有的食物，然后在同一个咖啡罐里呕吐，我可以通过重量判断吐出了多少。
But that's one of the things that I don't want to do that. How complicated and time consuming and just humiliating is that? And the voice is like, yeah, but do you really want to run the risk of leaving some extra food in there?
但这只是我不希望做的事情之一。这有多复杂、耗时和羞辱人？而那个声音就像是，是啊，但你真的想冒着留下一些额外食物的风险吗？
The voice definitely brings in also an element of shame. It says, you want everyone to think that you have money. You want everyone to see that you're generous and you can give and put yourself out there financially. It will prove that you're not a poor kid.
那个声音肯定也带来了一个羞耻的元素。它说，你想要每个人都认为你有钱。你想要每个人都看到你是慷慨的，你可以给予，并在经济上表现自己。这将证明你不是一个贫穷的孩子。
And it also says a lot of mean things, too. Your husband's too good for you, you may as well have a glass of wine because without it you won't be as entertaining.
而且它也说了很多刻薄的话。你丈夫对你太好了，你最好喝杯酒，因为没有它你就不会那么有趣了。
When we decided to get engaged and we had been living together for a little while, the voice was like, you tricked him into giving you the ring, OK, that's a start. But you better try your hardest to make sure he doesn't take it away, because he's going to find out the truth about you and how much you suck. So you better distract him with a really thin body.
当我们决定订婚并且我们住在一起一段时间后，那个声音就像，你骗他给你戒指，好吧，这是一个开始。但你最好尽最大努力确保他不会把它拿走，因为他会发现关于你的真相以及你是多么糟糕。所以你最好用一个非常瘦的身体来分散他的注意力。
Well, let me just do this one. If I pop it, I'll have smooth skin, my skin will look nice after I do this. I've definitely scarred my skin. I can see the scars, even though I'm wearing makeup and everything.
好吧，让我做这个吧。如果我挤掉它，我会有一个光滑的皮肤，我做完这个后我的皮肤看起来会很好。我肯定让我的皮肤留下了疤痕。我可以看到疤痕，即使我化了妆什么的。
It's the same thing and it always pushes me the same direction, and I'm always the same 40 minutes late.
这都是一样的东西，它总是把我推向同一个方向，我总是迟到 40 分钟。
I think I probably gave the bank over $2,000 in service charges. That voice. It was so charming.
我想我大概给了银行超过 2000 美元的服务费。那个声音。它太迷人了。
I think one thing that got me in a standoff against the voice this year was I slept with a guy who has a girlfriend, and she's kind of a bigger girl. And he had slept with a bunch of other girls in town that I knew. And they were all heavy girls. And I slept with him, and I was thinking to myself, I must have rocked his world, because I'm thin and he's used to these fat girls. And then I found out he was going around town saying that having sex with me was like having sex with a pile of paper clips, which is not nice.
我想有一件事让我今年站在了那个声音的对立面，就是我跟一个有女朋友的家伙睡了，她是个块头比较大的女孩。他跟城里我认识的其他几个女孩也睡过。她们都是胖女孩。我跟他睡了，我在想，我一定震撼了他的世界，因为我很瘦，而他习惯了这些胖女孩。然后我发现他在城里到处说，跟我做爱就像跟一堆回形针做爱，这可一点也不好听。
And for a couple of days I was kind of like, you know, maybe you're wrong, voice. Maybe you're wrong and maybe I should gain weight and maybe I should stop sleeping with these men. And that lasted for a couple of days and then the voice was like, when he said pile of paper clips, all the other girls were jealous when they heard that. And at least he's talking about you. At least you made an impression on him.
有几天我有点像是，你知道，也许你错了，声音。也许你错了，也许我应该增肥，也许我不应该再跟这些男人睡了。这持续了几天，然后那个声音就像，当他说一堆回形针时，当其他女孩听到那个时，她们都嫉妒了。而且至少他在谈论你。至少你给他留下了深刻的印象。
No matter what they say, the voice turns it into a compliment.
无论他们说什么，那个声音都会把它变成恭维。
Do you feel like the voice is winning?
你觉得那个声音正在赢吗？
Right now, yeah. I think I'm in some serious trouble, to be honest.
现在，是的。老实说，我觉得我有大麻烦了。
Thanks to everybody who talked with us. That story from Nancy Updike.
感谢所有跟我们交谈的人。那是南希·厄普代克的报道。
[MUSIC - "LEXICON DEVIL" BY THE GERMS]
[音乐 - 德国乐队的《LEXICON DEVIL》]
Act three, The Devil Wears Birkenstocks. Well, we've heard today from people who are battling all kinds of inner demons. David Dickerson has done that, and he's gone one step further.
第三幕，魔鬼穿着勃肯鞋。好吧，我们今天听到了那些与各种内在恶魔搏斗的人的声音。大卫·迪克森做到了，而且他更进一步。
When I was 23 years old and wrestling with my faith, the last big battle for my soul came when I had to face down an actual demon who was a guest in one of my university classes. Or that's how I saw it at the time. But the battle had started long before, when I was a kid. I had been raised a fundamentalist Christian. Adam and Eve, the flood, David and Goliath, all  of that really happened. Jesus walked on water and was born of the Virgin and said everything that the four gospels tell us.
当我 23 岁并与我的信仰作斗争时，我灵魂的最后一场大仗是我必须直面一个真正的恶魔，他是我的大学班级的客人。或者至少当时我是这么看的。但这场战斗早在很久以前就开始了，当我还是个孩子的时候。我是在原教旨主义基督教的环境下长大的。亚当和夏娃、洪水、大卫和歌利亚，所有这些都是真的发生了。耶稣在水面上行走，由童贞女所生，并说了四福音告诉我们的一切。
But after years of religious studies classes at the University of Arizona, I felt myself swerving toward a moderate Catholicism and wasn't quite sure about many of the things I had been raised to believe. The history of the Bible wasn't as pure as I had been taught. I was questioning inconsistencies, like how simple textual analysis pretty much proves Paul didn't write the book of Hebrews. Basic facts about the nature of Jesus, of God, of our duties on this earth seemed to me less like eternal truths and more like things I happen to believe.
但在亚利桑那大学学习了多年的宗教研究课程后，我感到自己正在转向温和的天主教，对许多我从小被教导要相信的事情不太确定。圣经的历史不像我被教导的那样纯粹。我质疑不一致之处，比如简单的文本分析证明保罗并没有写《希伯来书》。关于耶稣、上帝、我们在地球上的职责的本质的基本事实，在我看来不太像永恒的真理，更像是碰巧我相信的事情。
But I was still sure about two things. There was a spiritual world behind what we could see, and it contained both good and evil spirits. Angels, that is, and demons. I believed this for a couple reasons. First of all, the Bible said so. Time and again in the gospels, a demon-possessed person will cross Jesus' path and then the demon inside the person snarls and curses. Jesus rebukes the demon, casts them out, and the person is healed.
但我仍然确定两件事。在我们能看到的东西背后有一个精神世界，它包含善灵和恶灵。也就是天使和恶魔。我相信这一点有几个原因。首先，圣经就是这么说的。在福音书中，被恶魔附身的人多次穿过耶稣的道路，然后那个人体内的恶魔咆哮并诅咒。耶稣斥责恶魔，把他们赶出去，那个人就痊愈了。
But beyond just the Bible, my sister and father had both seen demons. They've always been kind of closet charismatics, and for a while our family was going to both kinds of services. Charismatic Christians are the ones who speak in tongues and lay hands on sick people. At that church, we got regular reports from visiting missionaries who would tell hair-raising stories about how they'd faced down local witch doctors who would suddenly yell at the missionaries in a strange voice and in perfect English, or cause spears to levitate over them menacingly.
但除了圣经之外，我的姐妹和父亲都见过恶魔。他们一直都是某种程度上的魅力型基督徒，有一段时间我们的家庭去了两种礼拜。魅力型基督徒是那些说方言并为生病的人按手祷告的人。在那间教堂，我们定期收到来自来访传教士的报告，他们会讲令人毛骨悚然的故事，讲述他们如何直面当地巫医，巫医会突然用奇怪的声音和完美的英语对传教士大喊大叫，或者导致长矛在他们头顶威胁性地悬浮。
I'd never actually seen a demon myself, but all of us Christian kids traded demon tales the way other kids swap ghost stories, and for the same reason, because it's scary, but exciting, but scary, but exciting. So even though years went by, and I still never saw a demon, a little sliver of that fear stayed with me and kept me on my guard, just in case. If I ever did meet one, I wouldn't make the mistake of treating it like a metaphor.
我自己从来没见过恶魔，但我们所有基督徒孩子交换恶魔故事的方式就像其他孩子交换鬼故事一样，原因也是一样的，因为这很可怕，但令人兴奋，很可怕，但令人兴奋。所以即使多年过去了，我仍然没见过恶魔，那一丝恐惧留在我心里，让我保持警惕，以防万一。如果我真的遇到一个，我不会犯把它当作隐喻的错误。
So anyway, at the time of this story, I was a college senior, and to fill out my last semester of electives, I decided to take a class called Paranormal Anthropology. This was about strange phenomena. Dowsing, UFOs, ESP, past life regression, all that stuff you find on the X- Files . And the professor was really interesting, because although our textbook was a skeptical look at all these things, he would bring in guest lecturers who were actual believers, so we could get both sides of the story.
总之，在故事发生的时候，我是一名大四学生，为了完成我最后一学期的选修课，我决定上一门名为《超自然人类学》的课。这是关于奇怪现象的。占卜、不明飞行物、超感知、前世回溯，所有你在《X 档案》里发现的东西。教授非常有趣，因为虽然我们的教科书是对所有这些事情的怀疑态度，但他会请来是真正信徒的嘉宾讲师，这样我们就可以从双方获得故事。
We were lectured one week by three UFO abductees. And the next week, we had a dowser try and trace the water mains on the University green. The dowser failed, and the abductees were weird. And, on the whole, it looked like science was winning.
我们有一周听了三位不明飞行物被绑架者的讲座。接下来一周，我们有一个占卜师试图追踪大学绿地上的自来水管道。占卜失败了，被绑架者很奇怪。总的来说，看起来科学正在获胜。
But then, one day, the professor announced that our guest next time would be a medium, a woman who channeled spirits. And she was going to let herself get possessed, right there in the classroom, two days from now. As soon as he said it, I was terrified. For all my book learning, in some raw, anxious way I was still 10 years old and overwhelmed. There was going to be a demon in this classroom-- an actual agent of spiritual evil-- who was counting on people not believing in him. People would ask this demon questions, and this demon would answer, speaking with the voice of Satan, and everyone would nod and no one would know the real agenda of this creature.
但后来，有一天，教授宣布我们下次的嘉宾将是一位灵媒，一个通灵的人。两天后，她要在教室里让自己被附身。他一说完，我就惊恐万分。尽管我有书本知识，但在某种原始、焦虑的层面上，我仍然是个 10 岁的孩子，被压垮了。教室里将会有一个恶魔——一个真正的精神邪恶代理人——他指望人们不相信他。人们会问这个恶魔问题，这个恶魔会回答，用撒旦的声音说话，每个人都会点头，没有人会知道这个生物的真实议程。
I was the only conservative Christian I knew of in that class, which meant that I was the only one who could save us from, well, from being corrupted by evil in some direct, horrible way. I wasn't at all sure what the demon would do or say. All I knew was that what had been a simple academic pursuit had suddenly turned into the most serious spiritual test of my life.
我是那个班里我所知的唯一的保守派基督徒，这意味着我是唯一能拯救我们的人，免受，嗯，免受被邪恶以某种直接的、可怕的方式腐蚀。我一点也不确定恶魔会做什么或说什么。我只知道，曾经是一个简单的学术追求突然变成了我一生中最严肃的精神测试。
Only, I was really not up to the task. My faith had wandered. I had gone to Catholic mass. I had several gay friends. I had said skeptical things about the authorship of Hebrews. Now it was as if the god of my old Christianity, the real God, the straightforward God, the God who the Bible plainly states is there and whom I had become too highfalutin to simply accept, was calling me back to the battlefield. And I had two days to get into spiritual shape.
只是，我真的不能胜任这个任务。我的信仰已经游离了。我去过天主教弥撒。我有几个同性恋朋友。我说过关于希伯来书作者身份的怀疑言论。现在就好像我过去信仰的上帝，真正的上帝，直率的上帝，圣经明确指出在那里的上帝，而我已经变得太高傲而不能简单接受上帝，正在把我召回战场。我有两天时间来进入精神状态。
I started fasting immediately, and holed up in my room for hours. I prayed, "Lord, Jesus, please protect me in this coming battle. Build a wall of protection around the classroom, and protect all my fellow students. Give me the wisdom to know what to say, the courage to face this evil in your name and please, please, please, please protect me."
我立即开始禁食，并把自己关在房间里几个小时。我祷告，“主耶稣，请在这场即将到来的战斗中保护我。在教室周围建立一道保护墙，保护我所有的同学。给我智慧去知道该说什么，给我勇气以你的名义面对这种邪恶，并且请，请，请，请保护我。”
I repeated this over and over for the next two days. I didn't watch TV. I didn't use my computer. I couldn't let anything distract me, because I knew that if I failed-- well, you probably saw The Exorcist , same idea. This was a magic monster, one who could probably smell the Holy Spirit dwelling inside me, and who would find some way to attack. All this was scary, but I have to admit, it was exciting, too, which is basically what the conservative Christian's whole life is like.
接下来的两天我反复这样念叨。我不看电视。我不使用电脑。我不能让任何事情分散我的注意力，因为我知道如果我失败了——好吧，你可能看过《驱魔人》，同样的想法。这是一个魔法怪物，一个可能闻到圣灵住在我里面的怪物，并且会想出某种方法来攻击。所有这一切都很可怕，但我必须承认，它也很令人兴奋，这基本上就是保守派基督徒的生活方式。
There's temptation on every side, you have to constantly immerse yourself in prayer, in the Bible, in the community of faith. But with that fear comes the thrill of getting to be an instrument of goodness in an evil world. And for me now, with this impending demon, here it suddenly was, years after I'd given up expecting it. I'd been groomed for this battle since I was a little kid. This was my chance to be a hero for the faith, just like my namesake, King David. I had read the Bible stories about him hundreds of times.
各方面都有诱惑，你必须不断沉浸在祷告、圣经、信仰社区中。但伴随着那种恐惧的是在邪恶世界中成为善良工具的快感。对我来说现在，面对这个即将到来的恶魔，它突然出现了，在我放弃期待它多年之后。我从还是个小孩子的时候就被培养来迎接这场战斗。这是我成为信仰英雄的机会，就像我的同名，大卫王。我已经读过几百遍关于他的圣经故事了。
I walked in the class that Thursday wearing a cross necklace I had lately been setting aside, and I slapped down my New International Version Study Bible right there in front of me on the table. I just stared at it and prayed and didn't talk to anyone. I was trembling, partly from fear and tension, and partly, of course, from hunger.
那个周四我走进教室，戴着我最近一直放在一边的十字架项链，我把我面前桌子上的新国际版研读本圣经摔在桌上。我只是盯着它祈祷，没跟任何人说话。我在颤抖，部分是因为恐惧和紧张，当然，部分是因为饥饿。
And then the medium came in, an overweight woman of about 55. Faded jeans, faded T-shirt, tacky bead necklaces and long, graying hair. She had a friend with her who acted as her assistant. And this friend, also frumpy, said that the medium often had several different spirits come through her in a session, so we might notice her voice changing.
然后灵媒进来了，一个 55 岁左右、超重的女人。褪色的牛仔裤，褪色的 T 恤，庸俗的珠子项链，长长的灰白头发。她有一个朋友作为她的助手。这个朋友，也穿着邋遢，说灵媒在一次会议中经常会有几个不同的灵魂通过她，所以我们可能会注意到她的声音在变化。
They dimmed the lights slightly. The medium went into her trance. And then her assistant said, she's just reached her spirit guide, who's an Indian chief from the Hopi tribe who died in the 1800s. Does anyone have any questions? An old sort of hippie-ish woman, an Indian spirit guide. This started seeming less sinister and more like something out of community theater.
他们稍微调暗了灯光。灵媒进入了恍惚状态。然后她的朋友宣布，她现在联系上了她的灵导，是一位 1800 年代去世的霍皮部落的印第安酋长。有人有问题吗？一个老式的、嬉皮士风格的女人，一个印第安灵导。这开始看起来没那么险恶，更像社区剧院里的东西。
But, of course I told myself, that's exactly what Satan would want me to think, because if the devil doesn't want us to believe in him, this was a really perfect disguise. But, then again, how would I know the difference?
但是，当然我告诉自己，这正是撒旦希望我想的，因为如果魔鬼不希望我们相信他，这是一个非常完美的伪装。但是，话又说回来，我怎么知道区别呢？
And just then, the medium moaned and rolled her head, and her friend announced, she is now channeling the spirit of King David. King David. Hell, I was a Bible scholar, this was my turf. I flipped to the Psalms, the book that David is supposed to have written, and found a question I had always been curious about. When the teacher asked, does anyone have a question for King David?, my hand shot up.
就在那时，灵媒呻吟着滚动着她的头，她的朋友宣布，她现在正在通灵大卫王的灵魂。大卫王。见鬼，我是一个圣经学者，这是我的地盘。我翻到诗篇，大卫被认为是作者的那本书，并发现了一个我一直很好奇的问题。当老师问，有人有给大卫王的问题吗？我的手举了起来。
The professor called on me and I rose to my feet. And, still staring intently at my open Bible, and with a voice that was actually quivering, I said, "Yes, um, King David? I notice here that some of your Psalms are called Maskils, and some are called Miktams, and according to my footnotes, these are musical terms. But scholars don't actually know what they mean. Could you please explain the difference?"
教授叫到了我，我站起身。仍然盯着我打开的圣经，声音实际上在颤抖，我说：“是的，嗯，大卫王？我注意到这里你的一些诗篇被称为‘Maskils’，一些被称为‘Miktams’，根据我的脚注，这些是音乐术语。但学者们实际上不知道它们是什么意思。你能解释一下区别吗？”
There was a brief pause. I was too scared to look at her face. Finally, the medium said, "Yes, I could explain. But the answer would be very technical, and I don't think it would interest anybody." And her friend said, "Next question."
有短暂的停顿。我太害怕了，不敢看她的脸。最后，灵媒说，“是的，我可以解释。但答案会非常技术化，我不认为它会引起任何人的兴趣。”她的朋友说，“下一个问题。”
It all happened so quickly that I wasn't sure how to understand it. I decided that the demon, who would clearly have known the answer, just didn't blurt it out because he wanted to avoid a fight with a real Christian. The second the bell rang, the women left the classroom without a word. I thanked God for the victory, and went to grab some pizza.
这一切发生得太快了，我不确定该如何理解。我决定，显然知道答案的恶魔只是没有脱口而出，因为他想避免与一个真正的基督徒打架。铃声一响，女人们一言不发地离开了教室。我为胜利感谢上帝，去买比萨吃。
While I was sitting at a booth, waiting for my slice to arrive, I mentally replayed exactly what had happened. And I realized that God hadn't technically won. A win for God would have been the demon calling me out in a creepy voice, and me brandishing the cross and saying, "In the name of Jesus, I command you," and maybe papers flying everywhere. Instead, what had happened was that a liar had come into our classroom, and I'd beaten her with scholarship.
当我坐在摊位上，等待我的比萨到来时，我在脑海中重放了到底发生了什么。我意识到上帝在技术上并没有赢。上帝的胜利应该是恶魔用阴森的声音叫我出来，我挥舞着十字架说，“以耶稣的名义，我命令你”，也许纸张到处飞。相反，发生的事情是一个骗子来到我们的教室，我用学术知识打败了她。
What's more, it hadn't even been close. Book learning had been easier, swifter, and more powerful than prayer and fasting combined. Right then, for the first time, I saw myself from the outside. And what I saw was that my belief in demons was actually kind of silly. My next immediate thought was, well, if demons don't exist except in stories I hear from other people, what about angels? For that matter, what about the Virgin birth? Oh, my god.
更重要的是，甚至没有接近。书本知识比祷告和禁食加起来更容易、更迅速、更有力。就在那时，我第一次从外面看到了自己。我看到的是，我对恶魔的信仰实际上有点愚蠢。我的下一个即时想法是，好吧，如果恶魔不存在，除了我从别人那里听到的故事，那么天使呢？就此而言，童贞孕呢？天哪。
And before I knew it, I felt like I was falling helplessly, because it turns out you can't actually make yourself believe something if the doubts seem more likely.
在我意识到之前，我觉得自己正在无助地坠落，因为事实证明，如果怀疑看起来更有可能，你其实无法强迫自己相信某事。
When I think about it now, that one rational question put to the demon, that shipwrecked my faith. I had kicked open one door too many, and I could no longer stay inside where I felt safe. For a few years, I kept going to church. I kept trying to believe. But after awhile, I let go altogether. If you ask my family, they'd claim that when I fought that nonexistent demon, Satan actually won, that he couldn't have chosen a better answer to make the whole idea of demons seem ridiculous, and kill my faith forever.
现在想起来，那个向恶魔提出的理性问题，破坏了我的信仰。我踢开了太多门，我再也无法待在让我感到安全的地方了。几年里，我一直去教堂。我一直试着去相信。但过了一段时间，我完全放弃了。如果你问我的家人，他们会声称当我对抗那个不存在的恶魔时，撒旦实际上赢了，他不可能选择更好的答案来让整个恶魔的概念看起来荒谬，并永远扼杀我的信仰。
Dave Dickerson in New York.
纽约的大卫·迪克森。
Well, our program was produced today by Sarah Koenig and myself, with Alex Blumberg, Jane Feltes, John Jeter, Lisa Pollak, Robyn Semien, Alissa Shipp, and Nancy Updike. Our senior producer is Jule Snyder, Adrianne Mathiowetz runs our website. Production help from Seth Lind, [UNINTELLIGIBLE] [? Navarro ?], Bruce Wallace and P.J. Vogt. Music help from Jessica Hopper. Happy birthday, Jessica.
好吧，我们的节目今天由萨拉·科尼格和我本人制作，亚历克斯·布隆伯格、简·费尔特斯、约翰·杰特、丽莎·波拉克、罗宾·塞米恩、阿丽莎·希普和南希·厄普代克参与。我们的资深制作人是朱尔·斯奈德，阿德里安娜·马蒂奥韦茨运营我们的网站。制作帮助来自赛斯·林德、[听不清] [? 纳瓦罗 ?]、布鲁斯·华莱士和 P.J. 沃格特。音乐帮助来自杰西卡·霍珀。生日快乐，杰西卡。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[致谢]
This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International.
《美国生活》由国际公共广播电台发行。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
[资助名单]
WBEZ management oversight for our program by our boss, Mr. Torey Malatia. And you know, part of management oversight is that he calls us into his office once a year for annual evaluations and reviews. I actually have right here a recording of one of the sessions.
WBEZ 对我们节目的管理监督由我们的老板，托里·马拉蒂亚先生负责。你知道，管理监督的一部分是他每年召集我们去办公室一次，进行年度评估和审查。我这里确实有一份其中一次会议的录音。
C'mon you can take it.
来吧，你能承受的。
Ah. [BLEEP]. Ah, [BLEEP].
啊。[BLEEP]。啊，[BLEEP]。
I'm Ira Glass, back next week, with more stories of This American Life .
我是艾拉·格拉斯，下周回来，带来更多《美国生活》的故事。
PRI, Public Radio International.
PRI，国际公共广播电台。